oh you who have believed
if someone untrustworthy comes
to you with an information with
a statement, with a testimony,
with a piece of news, then do
not accept it and react to it
until you verify.
And do not be hasty to react to
this news before verification
Lest you be very hasty and harm
another people in your haste
based on faulty information and
end up remorseful over that. He
says Allah and know that
amongst you is the messenger of
Allah. This statement here,
know that amongst you is the
messenger of Allah If we look
at this verse and we look at
all of the etiquettes that came
previously in this chapter thus
far. Not perceiving Allah and
his messenger. that we do
not raise our voices above the
voice of the messenger.
We do not call out to him in
his lifetime until he emerges
to us. That we not accept the
testimony or news or
information from someone who is
not trustworthy until we
verify. All of these things.
All of these etiquettes. If we
were to really sum these
etiquettes up and say I want
you to extrapolate each one of
these etiquettes from one
statement. That statement could
be and know that amongst you is
the messenger of Allah. And if
we really looked at it from
that perspective that the
messenger of Allah he sent to
us from Allah bearing the
message of Allah We have no
chance we have no chance of
revival. We have no chance of
salvation without receiving his
message. We have exaltation of
the messenger is a part of
exaltation of Allah is a part
of the exaltation of his
message that comes to us
etcetera. If we were to look at
the logical conclusions that we
would arrive at if we really
were able to do so and only had
one piece of information and
know that the messenger of
Allah is amongst you. This
alone could be something that
summarizes all of the
previously mentioned etiquettes
and this is something that we
will discuss in more detail
tomorrow inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]